SPEAKER 1: Please welcome to
Talks at Google, Joe and Joyce
Ellwanger.
SPEAKER 2: All right.
Well, thank you, everyone.
And thank you Joe and Joyce
for joining us here today.
It's truly an honor.
And we'll go ahead and
get started with the years
prior to 1965.
What brought you to
Birmingham, Alabama in 1958?
REV. JOSEPH ELLWANGER:
Well, the short version
is that my father was in Selma
as a pastor and president
of Alabama Lutheran
Academy and College, which
was a black high school
and junior college
serving the black Lutheran
Churches in Alabama.
I graduated from Concordia
Seminary in Saint Louis.
And my first call-- partly
because of my father's presence
in Selma, where I did
some of my growing
up, and because of my internship
in the black congregation
in Kansas City, I wound
up getting the call
to the black congregation
in Birmingham, Alabama.
And I've often said that I'm
grateful that my first call
to a parish was not to
Bismarck, North Dakota in 1958,
but to Birmingham, Alabama.
Because it certainly changed
my understanding of myself,
my theology, what pastoral
ministry is about,
and my understanding
of US history.
I am the recipient of
a lot of good things
that happened because of that.
SPEAKER 2: Absolutely.
Turning to the social
and political landscape
in Birmingham as it
shifted from 1958 to 1965,
what did that look like?
And also, if you could talk
about some of your work
with Dr. Martin Luther
King, Jr. during that time.
REV. JOSEPH
ELLWANGER: Well, 1958
was three years-- two years
after the Montgomery bus
boycotts, which was
really the spark that
started the civil rights
movement, 1955 to 1956.
So here's 1958.
The civil rights movement
is-- we won't say sputtering,
but it hasn't taken
off after Montgomery.
Montgomery was an amazing,
amazing indication
that not only is there a lot of
unrest in the black community,
especially as soldiers
came back from World War
II and the Korean War,
and then came back
to segregation and to
the kind of oppression
that they experienced
in the south.
There was a lot of
unrest-- a deep unrest
in the black
community-- demonstrated
by the bus boycott which was 95%
successful for an entire year.
This blew the minds of
white folks in the south
and of the media.
Nobody expected them to do that.
But then from 1956 on-- as the
Southern Christian Leadership
Conference was formed
by Dr. King and some
of the other civil
rights fighters--
there was a little
bit of a lull.
But there was that feeling
that something's happening,
something's going to take place.
And it really did
blow off in 1960
when we experienced the sit-ins.
And nobody orchestrated that.
It was just
spontaneous combustion
from the black campuses
all through the south,
and then it spread to the north.
And then, 1961 and 1962 were
such things as the attempted
entrance of blacks to
universities and colleges
in the south and things were,
obviously, breaking loose.
Dr. King and the Southern
Christian Leadership Conference
had their first major
demonstrations in the South
after Montgomery in
Albany, Georgia in 1962.
But that didn't go very far.
And so it looked as
though things were really
beginning to diminish
in the south,
in terms of this
movement for change,
until 1963 in Birmingham.
And for me to be there
in the middle of that
was quite a gift.
SPEAKER 2: Absolutely.
And so Joe and Joyce,
we'll turn to 1965.
If you could just
talk a bit about what
happened on March 6, and then
your involvement in the Selma
to Montgomery marches.
REV. JOSEPH ELLWANGER:
Well, to start with,
the evening of March 5--
the night before-- Joyce
and I didn't get a
whole lot of sleep.
JOYCE ELLWANGER: None.
REV. JOSEPH ELLWANGER:
It was-- because we
knew that leading
a march-- this was
the first-- to be the first
march of white southerners
in support of the
civil rights movement.
It had never happened.
And folks, black and white,
didn't think this would happen.
And we didn't know
what kind of response
we were going to get
in Selma the next day.
It could be anything
from some kind
of a vicious attack
from the Ku Klux Klan
to arrests to who knew?
It was very, very uncertain.
So we didn't sleep too
well that night before.
But then the day
of, we had no idea
how many white folks from
the whole state of Alabama
would show up for
this demonstration.
We had put out an invitation
and from the understanding
of how many white
moderates there were,
there could have been 500.
But given the threats and
the uncertainty of it all,
it could be Joyce and me.
SPEAKER 2: Right.
REV. JOSEPH ELLWANGER:
We really didn't know.
So we were very
grateful that there
were 72 who showed up,
counting Joyce and me.
And we had a preparation
for this event.
We walked down the main street
of Selma-- Broad Street.
It was a Saturday
right around noon.
And it was like a
Saturday in Selma.
Folks were going to the
stores-- the drugstore--
and we were walking down
a Broad Street sidewalk.
No big deal, it seemed.
Nothing was happening.
They looked at us and
wondered who we were
and why we were there until
we got to the corner of Broad
Street and Alabama,
where we had to turn
to go one block to
the courthouse, which
was our destination.
And when we turned
the corner, we
could see in the
street-- Lauderdale,
there-- in front of the
courthouse about 300,
400 white men with pipes
and clubs and bats.
And we knew that they were
not there for a party,
unless you want to talk
about a negative party.
And as we came up to the corner
then, they were to our right.
And right in front of us, was a
phalanx of about seven or eight
sheriff's deputies.
And to our left, which we
really didn't notice immediately
because we were transfixed
on this group to the right--
but to the left were
about 400 or 500 blacks
on the lawn of the
federal building, which
was opposite the courthouse.
So here we were in
the middle of it
all, stopped by the
sheriff's deputies.
And the Sheriff deputy in
charge looked down at his hand
and stopped us and said,
I have a telegram here
from Dr. Homrighausen.
Do you know him?
By the way, that's the picture
on the front of my book.
But as the Sheriff's deputy
looked down at his hand,
he said, I have a telegram.
Do you know him?
Well, he happens
to be the president
of the district of our
Lutheran Church Missouri Synod.
He's like my bishop.
Well, he said, I have
a message from him.
And the first sentence,
as he read it,
was the Reverend
Joseph Ellwanger
does not represent the
Lutheran Church Missouri
Synod in any way in his
actions in Selma today.
Well, what do you say to that?
And if he expected me to
turn around to go home,
he was sadly mistaken.
I said well, Dr.
Homrighausen has his right
to his own opinions,
but we're here
today to stand in solidarity
with our black brothers
and sisters who have been
struggling here for two months
to simply be able to vote.
And we came to
support them and we'd
like to move forward to the
steps of the courthouse.
And at that point, we had no
idea what was going to happen.
That's where the uncertainty was
going to become very certain.
Either we were
going to be arrested
or they were going
to give the signal
to the yocals in the street.
And when you think
about that for a moment,
here are seven Sheriff's
deputies permitting
500 white men with bats
and clubs and pipes,
standing in the street,
you know which side
the Sheriff's deputies are on.
And so they could easily have
just given the signal and said,
go ahead for it.
We'll turn around for
about five minutes
and we'll see what happens.
But strangely enough, the
Sheriff's deputies moved apart
and we moved forward,
had our demonstration,
and managed to make it back to
our place where we came from.
But I think, maybe, Joyce
needs to tell her perspective.
JOYCE ELLWANGER: Well, I just
wanted to say a little bit more
about who these 72 people
were at that walk together.
We'd had nonviolence
training, so we
knew how to protect
ourselves, our own bodies,
and how to react to the kinds
of hate speech and things
that we might encounter.
They said there
would be no police
protection at all for us.
It was an interfaith group.
There were Jews and
Unitarians and people
who were mainline Baptists
and Christian groups.
And a few that weren't
affiliated, but supported us
in what we were trying to do.
We lined up two by two.
And in those days, people
wore their Sunday clothes.
They dressed up.
Women were in heels.
It's hard to picture a
demonstration these days
that would look like that.
But we were dressed
to be out and about.
So we lined of two by two.
I was near the end of the line.
I was pregnant at the time
and Joe didn't want me really
up front.
We had talked about that.
But I lined up with a pastor
who came from Clanton, Alabama,
where there was a hotbed
of the Ku Klux Klan.
He had had a cross
burned on his churchyard
because he had spoken
up for voting rights
and how this was really a
moral issue that people needed
to be concerned about, and how
it was very fundamental to what
it meant to be a
democracy and to support
the values of our
country, as well.
So he had experienced
some real hateful things
that had happened and
threats to his congregation
and to himself.
And that man was really scared.
Talk about knees knocking.
He was literally-- his
knees were knocking.
He was shaking.
But he found the courage
to overcome that fear.
Fearful as he was, he
came and he got in line
and he walked with us.
And it was such a lesson about
being able to overcome fear.
I think we're going to talk
in a little bit about today
and the kinds of fears
and the kinds of hate
that we have to overcome.
And it's not easy.
And it can be scary.
But here was an
example of someone
who was able to do that,
and to come and walk.
And risk-- and
risk a great deal.
And so I was so grateful
and learned a lot from him.
Joe told the story of what
happened at the courthouse,
but as we got ready to leave,
one of the deputies came over
and he said, Joe.
He said, I don't
think you better
go back the way you came.
Because the white
men with their clubs
were blocking the
way in-- closing in.
He said, why don't you
just go the other way?
When we did, three
songs were being sung.
We had sung "America
the Beautiful"
as part of our witness
at the courthouse steps.
Can you guess what
the guys were singing?
"Dixie."
And then, we looked over to
our African-American friends
and we were walking
right through the middle
of their group, or
right past them,
and they were singing
"We Shall Overcome."
And I can't tell
you what a feeling
it was to have done
our little witness
and known that these people
had come out risking maybe
being identified, maybe
risking losing their job,
even, if you can imagine just to
have come as a show of support
for us.
To help protect us,
to stand with us.
Maybe just to see if we'd
even show up, some of them.
But there we were.
And as we walked
through, they were
singing "We Shall Overcome."
That's a song some of us still
sing today, once in a while.
And for the first few
years when I sang it,
I was in tears, remembering
what that was like.
I can't tell you what
a feeling of solidarity
and of support and
of coming together
as people who really understood
what the issues were.
And were ready to work together
to see that change would come.
SPEAKER 3: What an
inspirational story.
There were some pivotal times
throughout your journey.
I think one of them
might have been one
that you might call premier.
That might be the time when
you had the opportunity
to meet with President
Lyndon Johnson.
Can you just tell
us a little bit
about why that meeting happened,
and possibly a little bit
about the aftermath, or outcome,
of that very pivotal meeting?
REV. JOSEPH ELLWANGER: The
meeting with President Lyndon
Johnson actually took place
the Friday after our march.
We were there Saturday,
the 6th of April.
And we need to remind ourselves
that the next day, April--
March 7, was Bloody Sunday.
And that really-- our
little demonstration,
in the big scheme of
things, was very minor.
The only real
significance was that it
was southern whites standing up
for the first time, publicly.
But the next day, 500 blacks
walking over the Edmund Pettus
bridge were just clobbered.
And it went over
national television.
And the whole nation began
to feel this call for change
that was coming from
blacks in the South
that was no small deal.
And so the meeting with
President Lyndon Johnson
was really orchestrated by the
National Council of Churches,
nationally.
And it was their attempt
to show that this is not
just a few people in Selma
that are asking for voting
rights for everybody.
But it's our-- there's national
support all over the country.
So the people who went--
there were about 15,
16 of us-- two or three
black ministers and the rest
were white ministers, one or two
from each major denomination.
So I was the token Lutheran, and
the only white southern pastor
that was in the group.
The rest were from
all over the country.
And we had our meeting
with President Johnson, who
had said that he wanted to stand
up for voting rights for people
in the south, particularly,
who had been disenfranchised.
But he didn't want
to do it right then.
He said, there's a time table.
I've got it all in mind.
But with all the things that
were happening, and especially
Bloody Sunday, it really began
to put the pressure on him.
And to meet with him
in the Oval Office
and around that--
it is an oval table.
And each of us had an
opportunity to say something.
I remember that, basically,
what I told him was,
I grew up in Selma, Alabama.
And I think that startled him
a little bit because he didn't
expect any white person in Selma
to be supporting the Voting
Rights Act.
But I said, I grew-- most of
my growing up was in Selma.
And I am a pastor in Alabama
and it really disturbs me deeply
that I have black colleagues
in Wilcox County and Dallas
County-- Dallas was the county
that Selma was county seat,
Wilcox right next to
it-- who cannot vote.
Pastors who have graduated from
college and seminary and they
cannot vote.
This is intolerable,
unacceptable,
and this has got
to change quickly.
Soon, not in the
next year or two.
I remember I really
stressed the urgency of it
and that I came from
Selma, for whatever impact
this had on President Johnson.
It was really a
cumulative effect
that happened as
Bloody Sunday, Friday
was the meeting of
the pastors and clergy
from around the country
with President Johnson.
And then, a week
later-- March 21--
finally, the Selma to
Montgomery march began.
So all of that was very
close together and all of it
was mounting push in
Washington-- in Congress
and in the White House-- for
a strong Voting Rights Act,
and soon.
And the amazing
thing is-- we look
at how long it takes to get
any bill through Congress,
for the Voting Rights Act to
actually pass from March of '65
to the end of
July-- what is that?
About three or four months.
And for it to be as strong
and as solid as it was-- it
was really something that,
within a year or two,
dismantled Jim Crow-- the
segregated way of life
in the south that whites
said would never happen.
And blacks, who
lived in hope that it
would be dismantled
some day, figured, maybe
by the end of the century.
So how important that
Voting Rights Act was
can never be underestimated.
It was but one of the most
important historical moments
in our nation's history.
And it happened because there
were people who stood up
and risked their lives and
their jobs to let the nation
and the president and the
Congress know that this cannot
go on as it is.
JOYCE ELLWANGER:
And we saw that when
we returned to Birmingham
some years later.
About every five years, we
would come back to visit.
And we were in the church
that Joe had served.
And sitting in the front row
was the mayor of Birmingham,
who was a black man.
Never before--
everybody-- the police,
the fire department-- anybody
in a position of power
in Birmingham had been white.
So here was the
mayor of the city
there to welcome us and
give Joe a key to the city--
the black mayor.
We met a woman who was
the chief of police
after the terrible Bull Connor
era, and others had been there.
And she was an
African-American woman.
And the council was integrated.
And in these counties, where
people-- a handful-- in some
places, not one person
had been a voter.
As they registered
and voted, the color
of the people who were in
charge-- the power structure--
began to change.
That's the kind of thing
Joe is talking about.
That was the transformation--
the power shift
that began to happen.
And that was so significant
to come back and see that.
It was almost
incredible to us, having
lived through the segregated
time, to see what was happening
and how change can come.
SPEAKER 2: Well, thank
you, Joe and Joyce,
for recounting those stories.
They're absolutely incredible.
And I think what
we'll do now is turn
toward a modern
application of the lessons
that you've learned through
your social justice advocacy.
And the first
question is, there's
been a lot of media coverage on
the refugee crisis in Europe.
And I just wanted to
hear a bit about the work
that you have done with refugees
here in the United States.
REV. JOSEPH ELLWANGER: Where we
got our experience as pastor--
I was pastor of Cross
Lutheran Church in Milwaukee
from '67 until 2001.
And it was in the
1970s that refugees
from the Vietnam
War-- the Hmong people
and Laotian people who
had befriended our US
military while we were
there in that war,
were in danger, of course,
once the war was over.
And so they asked
for asylum and they
were refugees who were
streaming into this country.
And our congregation supported
them and sponsored some
families, in spite of the
fact that our congregation was
an urban congregation with
65%-- at that point, about 60%,
65% African-American membership.
And we could have said that
this is not really our calling
and this is not for us to do.
But we felt that we
needed to make it clear
that our country welcomes people
who have experienced oppression
and experienced danger.
And we should welcome them.
So we had a whole series
of refugees and immigrants
that we sponsored, then,
from Haiti, from Guatemala.
We had a Guatemalan
refugee in sanctuary,
which is a whole 'nother story.
But the end result was
that all of this experience
in walking with people
from different cultures
and coming with the
shirt on their backs
was an enriching
experience for us.
And I think every person and
certainly every faith community
should have the experience
of receiving and welcoming
people who don't speak
your language, who
have a different culture.
It blows us out of
our isolation and out
of our self-centeredness
to recognize that we're
part of a global village
and to recognize it
in a real way-- not
just in an academic
and an intellectual way.
So that was a really
rich experience
that has catapulted
us to this stage
to recognize that we really--
as the nation that stands
for freedom, as well as the
people of faith who recognize
the value of every
individual-- should
be in the forefront of welcoming
immigrants and refugees,
not throwing up-- talking
about building walls
and making it difficult
for people to come.
JOYCE ELLWANGER: I think
the learning, too-- these
are people fleeing war
in their own countries.
And with the Sanctuary
Movement, our government
was not supporting these
people or recognizing the death
threats and the
kinds of things that
were the realities of our own
US foreign policy, in regard
to places like El
Salvador and Guatemala.
And so there was
some risk for people
who were involved in
the Sanctuary Movement,
if you know anything about it.
There was a possibility of a
$5,000 fine or imprisonment
for a number of
years for people.
So it was not an easy thing
for a congregation to say,
we're going to take this
person into the sanctuary
and the protection
of the church.
And it opened a door
for a lot of discussion
of what our faith values
and roots that say we
welcome the stranger
in our land?
And I think the lesson for
today, too-- many people
are still fleeing
the wars that are
part of our US foreign policy.
And now we're
putting up barriers
to them coming into our country.
So it's a time to re-examine
those values, especially
those faith values
and those moral values
that we hold about
welcoming people.
And all of those undocumented
people in our country
who have lived here and
raised their children
and been good citizens and still
can't have a driver's license,
can't get insurance for
a car if they're driving.
Can't be-- they're just
not able to enter fully
into the society, although
they fully support the economy.
And so there are just a lot
of issues under the surface
that maybe we need to revisit.
And especially, I think how
our US foreign policy affects
the growing number of
people who are having
to flee, be displaced
in their own countries,
and outside of countries.
And who's going to welcome them?
And who are the people
best equipped to do that?
As one of the wealthiest
countries in the world--
we're a country of immigrants--
it seems to me, that's us.
And I'm really distressed that
we aren't doing more right now
to help those people who
are also fleeing those wars.
SPEAKER 3: Thus far,
we've inquired with you
about your past experience.
Because of that, now we
want to take a moment
and reflect on some
of your thoughts.
We want you to tell
us how exactly you
feel about the
international social justice
issues like human trafficking.
And what you think we, as a
people-- as global citizens--
can actually do to address that.
REV. JOSEPH ELLWANGER:
One of the basic lessons
that we learned in the '60s
and we dare never forget
is that the movement for
justice is never complete.
It's never ended.
We can never say,
well, now we have
just society in a just
world, where everyone
is treated with dignity.
And by the way, I
would-- we would not
have any right to talk about
our involvement in the 1960s
if we were not involved
right now in such an issue
as you mentioned here,
human trafficking.
Which can certainly
be understood and seen
as modern day slavery and an
example of an injustice that
has to be opposed.
And how do we deal with it?
Well here's a lesson from the
'60s that we dare not forget.
And that is that it
was because people
came together,
organized, and clearly
set goals for themselves
and cut issues-- that's
organizers jargon for
taking the massive problems
and figuring out a
point at which we
can puncture the balloon.
And we can attack human
trafficking as the big problem,
but we have to do it
on the local level
and we have to do it
with organized people who
are willing to stand up for
what is right and to take risks.
I will never forget
that CT Vivian, who
was one of the real champions
in the Selma movement,
told me about five
years ago when
we were in Selma for the
anniversary of Bloody
Sunday-- there's always
that anniversary.
If anybody really wants to get
a feel for both the experience
and the importance of
the Selma movement,
try the Bloody
Sunday commemoration.
It's really powerful.
So I was there five years
ago, for the 50th anniversary,
and CT Vivian came
over to our table.
We were eating in
the hotel restaurant.
And he said, you know, Joe,
when you look at what our humble
efforts here in
1965 accomplished,
do you realize that that means
that there is no problem--
no injustice-- in this
country that we cannot make
a difference with if we
organize, if we stay committed,
and if we're willing
to take risks?
And those are the three big ifs.
JOYCE ELLWANGER: The other
thing is most of us in Milwaukee
didn't realize that Milwaukee
is one of the real hotbeds--
the real centers--
for human trafficking
in the whole country.
Who would have thought?
You don't.
This is-- it's not an issue
that surfaces that easily.
And so that's been a
real learning for us.
And we have a strong human
trafficking committee
that meets monthly and
has engaged our mayor
and the powers that be
to really understand
the dimensions of that
in our own community.
Because it's under the surface.
You're not going to
necessarily be aware of it
unless you're educated about it.
And so that's so
true of education
around the issues
that are right there.
And many people live
in a bubble and either
choose not to see them
or really don't know.
So education is one
of the first steps
in being able to mobilize
people if they really
understand the problem is
right here, and it's us.
It's our problem.
SPEAKER 2: I just wanted
to hear a bit more
about your involvement with
the women's and LGBT movements.
And just to hear of
some of your thoughts
on the advances for
those movements,
and also some of the
hurdles to those movements.
REV. JOSEPH ELLWANGER:
Well, we have
to honestly say that our
nation and people of faith
have had to really
struggle with that issue
because our culture had
told us, and still tells us,
that LGBT people are
people who are heterosexual
and they just chose
to be that way.
And they're playing a game,
or at least, it's not right
and they need to just shape
up and be heterosexual.
And what our nation and what
most of the church-- now,
there are certainly some pockets
in the church and the faith
community that are still
kicking in their heels on this,
but most people have
come to recognize,
as our nation has-- especially
in the last few years--
that LGBT people
are people who have
this as part of their
DNA, part of who they are.
It's the way they
are born, just as I
was born as a heterosexual.
And that's hard
for heterosexuals
to recognize and
admit and to realize.
But once you come to that point,
then receiving and accepting
LGBT people with dignity
is something that not only
can happen-- that must happen.
Our congregation in Milwaukee
had the struggle back
in-- this was back in the
late 1980s and early 1990s.
And we had the
interesting struggle
to come to terms
with this and make
the decision-- are we going
to really be a Reconciling
In Christ congregation?
Which is what we
used, and still use,
in the Lutheran church as a
way of saying that we believe
in the dignity and equality of
every person, including LGBT.
And are we going to become
a Reconciling In Christ
congregation, or are we going
to just try to sit this out?
JOYCE ELLWANGER: It didn't
happ-- it didn't just happen.
We spent a year in Bible study
and really-- digging really
deeply into our what our
scriptures have to say.
And predominately
African-American congregation--
many people had grown up
in very conservative ways,
thinking homosexuality is a sin.
And the LGBTQ community was
one they hadn't experienced.
We had an office inside
of the church for a group
that we started called
Project Return that
was working with people coming
out of the prison system
and helping them reintegrate--
to find jobs and housing
and reintegrate
into the community.
And the director was a gay man.
And it's when he stood
before the congregation--
we had our first
coming out Sunday.
And he came and
he told his story
of his struggle-- how he tried
to change, all of the prayer,
and all the things he went
through with his family
and his own trying to
discover who he was,
and trying to be someone that
he wasn't and how that affected
him.
And then, when he accepted
who he was and he really
shared this with the
congregation in a heartfelt--
just such a beautiful way.
And at the end of
that testimony--
this was someone they had
known, but they hadn't really
known him as a gay man.
And when he came out
to the congregation,
there was about a
four or five minute
standing ovation for him.
Because suddenly, this
person that they had known
had shared his
heart and his soul.
And there was that feeling
of, well, this is Tim.
And we loved Tim.
And he's helped us to see,
in a new way, who he is.
And we love him as he is.
And so that's the kind of
thing that happens when
people have that opportunity.
So many people
haven't had that kind
of an experience
of really getting
to know the heart and
soul of someone who
is a part of that community.
One of the things we did,
too, as a congregation
to bring witness.
There's a parade at-- we
have a lakefront festival
and there are different
ethnic groups that have events
to celebrate their ethnicity.
And there is the weekend when
we have gay pride weekend.
And so the congregation would
take our congregational van,
with the name of the
church on the side,
and some of the older
members would ride inside,
and we would walk alongside
in the gay pride parade.
Just to say, we are here and we
are affirming this community.
And that kind of public witness
on the part of, I think,
people of faith is
really important, too.
It's not just doing something
inside your own group
or your own heart, but it's
giving that public witness that
can help other people
to stop and think
about their own feelings and to
begin to deal with some of it.
SPEAKER 3: We want to give way
for a little time for those
that are in the audience
to be able to pose
some questions to you.
And our last question
before we go to our Q&A--
because we're a
technological company,
I think that this would
be a perfect way to segue.
How do you feel
technology has altered
the behavior of the social
movement in modern society?
And tell me how
you view technology
as an actual catalyst
for social change.
REV. JOSEPH ELLWANGER:
There's absolutely no doubt
that modern technology has
been at the heart and the core
of a couple of-- well,
many recent movements,
including Black Lives Matter,
including the Arab Spring.
All of those movements
would not have
been able to muster
the number of people
without that kind of
communication system.
And it would have been very
difficult to communicate
the underlying basis of the
movement, and theme, and goal
of the movement.
And it's just a perfect
tool for organizing
and that's one of
the real pluses
that I will give to
technology today.
It definitely is a big,
big boost for organizing.
SPEAKER 3: We want to
give an opportunity
to those that are in
the seats, if there
be any that would have
any questions that you'd
like to pose to the Ellwangers.
SPEAKER 2: Got microphones to
the sides here if you want to--
SPEAKER 3: Yeah.
We have a person here, Josh.
Yep.
You can just go to the mic.
AUDIENCE: Based on your
historical experience,
it feels, today, that
there are movements,
but they're not
having fast enough.
The progress made with Black
Lives Matter, the progress made
with Arab Spring, et cetera-- it
seems that there's potentially
even more fear than ever today.
And it doesn't
feel like progress
is happening fast enough.
Based upon your
experience in the '60s,
did you feel the same way then?
Or did you see things
happening more quickly
because people were rallying
very tightly together
to get things done?
REV. JOSEPH ELLWANGER: It's a
very, very important question
for people who are going to
take seriously a commitment
to working on justice.
If we think that we are going
to solve human trafficking
and voter suppression and
joblessness in the central city
and mass incarceration
and poverty
and on with a long list of
really serious injustices
that everyone should be
concerned about-- if we think
we're going to solve these
in the next year or two,
we're badly mistaken.
And that is a reason
why some people shy away
from becoming involved
because they realize,
whoa, man, these are
such huge problems.
And look how long it took
for slavery to be eliminated.
How long it took for
women's suffrage,
how long it took to get
rid of child employment.
And how long it took to finally
get a strong Voting Rights
Act, and then get the
push back that we've
gotten in the last few years.
What's the use?
Well, what we have to
keep in mind is that,
as Margaret Mead once said,
never doubt that a few people
organizing-- coming together--
around a given issue cannot
make a difference.
That really is the only way that
any change has ever happened
and the only way that
change will happen.
And we really have to have
the vision for the long haul.
As a person of faith
and a Christian,
I truly believe--
and by the way,
Martin Luther King
was constantly having
to deal with that very issue.
Look how long we've
been working at bringing
about the end of segregation.
Not only-- it didn't just
begin with the Montgomery bus
boycott.
But if you started
there and count
that as the beginning,
here it is 1960,
1963, 1965-- look at how
many people went to jail,
look at how much has been
paid, and where are we?
There is that
constant uncertainty
about the value of
working for justice.
And at the end of the
Selma to Montgomery march,
Dr. King said something that he
used at the end of two or three
other times with his speeches.
But never to be forgotten.
How long is it going
to be before we
get the end of segregation?
In this case, that
was our issue.
Not long, he said.
Truth crushed to
earth will rise again.
How long will it take?
Not long, because those who
sew that-- whatever we sew,
we shall reap.
How long?
Not long, because the moral
arc of the universe is long,
but it bends toward justice.
And so that belief that we're
not just fighting by ourselves,
but that God is on our side.
This is spiritual
language, but that's
what God is all about--
bringing about justice,
bringing healing, bringing
reconciliation and redemption.
And therefore, the
really important thing
is to make sure we're
on the right side
and not on the wrong side.
And that we are doing
something to bend
that moral arc of the universe.
That was Barack
Obama who picked up
on that image of the moral
arc of the universe is long,
but it bends toward justice.
And he said, and we have
to be pushing on that arc
to hurry up that
move toward justice.
So it takes commitment, knowing
that change can take place,
believing that it
will take place.
But knowing all along that we
have to constantly be vigilant
and be alert.
Because even when we arrive
at the point of demolishing
segregation-- racial
segregation, legal segregation,
we know that there's been
the push back and there's
de facto segregation.
And there is white
flight and there's
all of that stuff that
means that we still
have some work to do.
And in the end, there
will be a victory.
Think of that song that was the
theme song of the civil rights
movement-- "We Shall Overcome."
That was not just a small little
ditty or a Sunday school song.
That was a song that
was sung by people
who had that deep commitment
that we shall overcome.
We don't know when.
We don't know whether that
march over the Edmund Pettus
bridge on Bloody
Sunday is really
going to produce a strong
Voting Rights Act this year
or 20 years from now.
But we shall overcome.
And that's the spirit in
which we have to do our work.
JOYCE ELLWANGER:
We're also working
for institutional kinds of
changes and that takes decades.
That doesn't happen in a year.
And it's power shifts,
and people don't willingly
give up power.
And so those are some of
the things to keep in mind.
And it's worth the struggle.
We stand on the shoulders of
the people who went before us.
We really do.
And so we have our opportunity
during our lifetime
to add our feet and our hands
and our hearts and our minds
to that and continue
that struggle.
But it's good to know we're up
against institutional change.
And that just is something
you work at over the decades.
And then, you have
to go back and you'll
see things coming,
like education,
and some of the issues that we
thought we had really won on.
And then you come
back and you have
the privatization of education,
of the prison systems,
of everything.
You have to go back and
just take a second breath
and say, well, let's do
what we can do in the time
that we have.
And then, timing is everything.
There are times-- and
I think right now,
the criminal justice--
the transformation
of criminal justice
around the country-- this
is a pregnant time for that.
So it's an issue that I
would hope that many of you,
if that's something
you're interested in,
really dig in and
work on it now.
Because the pendulum is
swinging and the more of us
that work at that, the more
change is going to come.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you so much
for that great question.
And thank you again, Joe and
Joyce, for everything today.
We really appreciate it.
And let's give them
a round of applause.